[Musik]
wir befinden uns am Beginn einer
dreiwöchigen Übung wo Teile der dritte
übrig hatte das Zusammenwirken im Rahmen
einer militärischen schutzoperation üben
jetzt konkret läuft eine
übersetzt Übung über die Donau wo
pionierkräfte der Welt die Übungsteile
über die Donau übersetzen die in
weiterer Folge den Übungsraum des
doppeltes einsteigt beziehen werden
den weiteren Verlauf der Übung werden
wir vor allem den Angriff im urbanen
Umfeld gegen irreguläre
Kräfte üben dabei werden die
verschiedenen Teile des Bataillons zum
Zusammenwirken gebracht
[Musik]
ein Attentäter hat einen Sprengsatz
deponiert diesen zu Explosion gebracht
und dieser Sprengstoff Sprengsatz war
mit chemischen Kampfstoff kontaminiert
es hat dann natürlich zu Folge dass
diese Kraftstoffe freigesetzt werden und
die Truppe entsprechende Maßnahmen
herstellen muss in erster Linie einmal
Schutzmaßnahmen für sich selbst anziehen
oder Aufsetzen der Schutzmaske eventuell
Anziehen des schutzanzüges die weiteren
Maßnahmen die dann von der ABC
durchgeführt werden das ist einmal als
erstes die ABC Aufklärung gleichzeitig
passiert der Aufbau des
dekontaminationsplatzes und dann
eventuell kontaminiertes Personal oder
Gefechtsfahrzeuge zu kontaminieren
[Musik]